[Music]
is Elliot on some apps swiping right
swiping left I mean listen I need to
know because I am curious about that
because you are in a very new place are
you looking for a relationship a partner
in your life I was very much a
relationship to relationship to
relationship person and it didn't mean
that obviously my the love and care
wasn't there for the first time
what feels like ever I'm really able to
be alone so I think that's something I'm
focusing on right now dating and stuff
and that's fun don't get me wrong
[Music]
you said that gender affirming surgery
has made you happier than you've ever
been in your entire life I can see that
on your Instagram I see that queer joy
that trans Joy on your face I don't know
how to describe it other than the fact
that I feel present to me and just
really feeling like myself for the first
time and not
consumed with the constant discomfort
and thoughts
and pain that did not allow me to live
my life fully before we all thought as
the public as fans that you would be on
cloud nine around Juno and that was
probably one of the darkest moments of
your life for so many reasons I'm able
to separate the making of the movie to
the promotional time of the movie so the
actual making of the film was wonderful
it was one of the best filmmaking
experiences I've ever had I loved
playing that character there's certain
elements of myself and my queerness that
made you know cool that made you know
special and and then that all got
squashed and the promotion of it which I
think back to and I just think that's so
gross how important is it for you to be
a voice now for the trans Community if
my story or
sharing certain moments of my life that
weren't necessarily easy to share or
moments that you feel shame about if
that does connect with people and and
help someone I mean that that means the
world to me
[Music]